cet homme Alfred Néron n'existe pas il
n'a pas de famille car il est né en Iran
45 à la suite d'une aventure amoureuse
entre un père qui est mort et une mère
anglaise qui n'a jamais voulu le
reconnaître et il n'a pas de nationalité
car son passeport iranien lui a été
retiré par la police du chat et la
citoyenneté britannique lui est refusé
par la Grande-Bretagne résultat de cette
âme Broglio administratif il vit depuis
deux ans à l'aéroport de Roissy en
situation illégale après avoir été
refoulé d'Allemagne de Hollande et de
Belgique
et d'avoir toujours été complètement
isolé hier comme aujourd'hui avoir une
nationalité sans être reconnue par son
pays c'est très douloureux
appartenir à une nation c'est avoir une
raison de vivre c'est appartenir à une
société à une communauté
de ce soir
avec ces deux bagages qui ne le quittent
jamais Alfred Meyran passe inaperçu
parmi les milliers de passagers en
transit dans la journée il lit où il se
promène au niveau départ le premier à
s'être occupé de lui c'est le médecin de
l'aéroport
il avait tendance à se clochardiser ce
marginaliser et très rapidement il y a
eu un réseau qui s'est installé autour
de lui il a été pris dans un maillage
social et ce qui s'est passé c'est que
il a remonté la pente et maintenant il
sera il est pris en charge par le réseau
souterrain de l'aéroport c'est le
premier citoyen de Roissy c'est un peu
l'avoir fait rentrer puis-je puissiez
sur ses papiers c'est ça
une traduction ou autre bon bah ils font
appel à lui puis en contrepartie d'un
atelier restaurant pour que j'aille
manger la cafétéria
pour sortir de l'impasse Alfred Meyrin a
pris un avocat qui essaie de lui obtenir
le statut d'apatride il pourrait alors
avoir un passeport et enfin voyager pour
rechercher sa mère en Angleterre mais
pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un rêve
[Musique]